sarah kommt vor 37 jahren in sri lanka
zur welt mit einem monat wird sie von
einem schweizer ehepaar adoptiert lange
interessiert sie sich nicht für ihre
herkunft doch dann nach und nach wächst
ihr wunsch nach ihren wurzeln zu suchen
dieser prozess hat sich über die jahre
entwickelt
es fühlt sich an wie kleine nadeln die
dich immer wieder stechen
aber du weißt gar nicht genau warum es
schmerzt ich bin hebamme von beruf und
habe schon so viele gesorgt so viele
male war ich bei diesem magischen moment
wenn eine mutter ihr baby in die arme
schließt ich hatte diese erfahrung
niemand konnte mir von diesem
emotionalen moment erzählen immer
stärker wird die bewusst dass etwas
fehlt umso mehr als die beziehung zu
ihren adoptiveltern schwierig ist
erst als sie selbst eine familie gründet
findet sie die kraft sich ihrer
vergangenheit zu stellen
durch die sicherheit die mir mein mann
und meine kinder gegeben haben konnte
ich mein schutzschild fallen lassen
ich wollte unbedingt herausfinden woher
ich komme und auch die kinder haben
begonnen mehr fragen zu stellen
mama wo ist meine großmutter hast du
brüder und schwestern und ich hatte
keine antwort
sarah weiß nichts über ihre leibliche
mutter aus sri lanka auch nicht weshalb
sie sarah verlassen hat von ihren ersten
lebenswochen hat sarah nur ein
schwarz-weiß-foto und sie ist sich nicht
einmal sicher ob das baby auf dem bild
wirklich sie selbst ist
im märz 2017 macht sich sarah auf die
suche nach ihren wurzeln
doch die reise entpuppt sich als
albtraum sie findet heraus dass ihre
papiere gefälscht sind
in sri lanka existiert sie nicht
[Musik]
in diesem armenviertel von colombo
findet sarah schließlich die adresse der
frau die als mutter auf ihrer
geburtsurkunde eingetragen ist im
dezember 2017 klopft sie bei ihr an die
tür
als wir ankamen war die ganze familie im
haus
wir erklärten weshalb wir da waren dass
wir diese frau suchen würden
sie kam und zeigte unseren pass sie
sagte ja das bin ich
und dann sagte sie mir aber ich bin
nicht eine man dennoch fühlt sich sarah
wohl mit der warmherzigen frau sie ist
sicher dass es ihrer mutter ist dass sie
es jedoch vor ihrer familie nicht
zugeben will
ich konnte es nicht glauben und sagte
ich möchte einen dna test machen lassen
sie war einverstanden und kam mit mir in
ein labor wo man ihr blut nahm für den
test ich suchte auf den fotos nach
ähnlichkeiten die augen die nase die
stirn
der mund ich wollte glauben dass sie
meine mutter ist auch damit ich aufhören
konnte meine familie zu suchen
als ich zurück in der schweiz war lag
das resultat des tests vor
sie ist mit 100 prozentiger sicherheit
nicht meine leibliche mutter
die frau gibt zu sie hat sich vor
gericht als mutter von sarah ausgegeben
damals gab ihr eine frau die sie nicht
kannte einige hundert dollar damit sie
die papiere unterschrieb sarahs mutter
hatte sie nie getroffen
im ersten moment dachte ich müsse
akzeptieren dass ich meine familie
niemals finden würde
ich war eine woche lang wirklich krank
und da war dieser schmerz in meinem
körper drin
wie tief diese verletzung ist
genau wie sarah sucht auch olivia in sri
lanka nach ihrer familie
die beiden haben sich dank eines dna
tests kennen gelernt er hat ergeben dass
sie entfernte cousinen sind
[Musik]
das war ein glücklicher zufall
wir sind beide in derselben kultur
aufgewachsen sprechen die gleiche
sprache deshalb sind wenig nach
wenn du gar nicht sie über deine
blutsverwandten weist dann denkst du
irgendwann du seist vom himmel gefallen
dass es nicht rational aber wenn man
jemanden findet mit dem man
blutsverwandt ist dann gibt einem das
die sicherheit dass es die eigene
familie einmal gab
oder vielleicht immer noch gibt
[Musik]
dieses gefühl von nirgendwo zu kommen
hat olivia in der jugend schwer zu
schaffen gemacht und dies obschon sie
mit liebevollen adoptiveltern in der
umgebung von zürich aufgewachsen ist
als sie im alter von 30 einen artikel
über das trauma bei adoptionen dienst
bietet plötzlich klar was der grund für
ihr tiefes unwohlsein ist ich erkannte
mich sofort in diesem artikel
ich war schockiert ich lernte in dieser
zeit so viel über mich ich konnte die
scham überwinden der ich bis zu jenem
zeitpunkt aufgebaut hatte wieso scham
weil ich immer dachte dass etwas mit mir
nicht stimmte oder dass ich eine
schlechte person war weil ich solche
gefühle hatte und plötzlich erfuhr ich
dass es eine erklärung für all das gibt
und das ist ein natürlicher vorgang ist
eine natürliche folge von dem was mir
bei der geburt widerfahren ist die
trennung und all das
nach dieser einsicht hat olivia vor zwei
jahren den mut gefunden nach sri lanka
zu reisen um herauszufinden wo sie
herkommt doch schnell hat sie gemerkt
dass es keinerlei angaben zu ihrer
geburt gibt
ich kenne den informationen auf meiner
geburtsurkunde nachname meine mutter
geburtsdatum eintrag des spitals in dem
ich zur welt gekommen sein soll
ich war sogar im heimatdorf millimeter
aber das waren alles sackgassen
niemand konnte irgendetwas sagen zu den
informationen die ich hatte
[Musik]
heute weiß olivia dass ihre
geburtsurkunde gefälscht wurde
genau wie die von sarah aber die beiden
cousinen geben nicht auf
sie verlangen einen termin auf dem amt
in colombo welches die adoption
verwaltet dort werden alle
originaldokumente aufbewahrt
wir haben hier nicht genügend
informationen um etwas herausfinden zu
können
wir haben gehofft dass auf der
geburtsurkunde bei ihnen informationen
zu finden sind die uns zu unseren
familien führen könnten
können sie uns da helfen das problem ist
die kinder adoptions verfügung
laut einem gesetz von 1946 braucht es
eine gerichtliche genehmigung um die
original dokumente einzusehen
das heißt im moment kann ich meine
geburtsurkunde nicht einsehen nein weil
sie das kind sind gemäss dieser urkunde
die frauen begreifen dass ihre dossiers
leer sind
also ich existiere nicht auf dem papier
wir wissen nicht was in dieser zeit
genau passiert ist nein ich bin vom
himmel gefallen nicht vom himmel
gefallen aber das ist so schwer das
gefühl zu haben dass man nicht existiert
wir wurden in diesem land geboren
dieses land ist ein teil von uns das ist
die verantwortung der eltern richtig
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll
es gibt nichts zu sagen ich bin
schockiert
sarah und olivia gehören zu den 750
babys die in den 80er jahren von
schweizern adoptiert werden
wegen des bürgerkriegs in sri lanka
damals ein regelrechtes eldorado für
adoptionen
insgesamt werden 11.000 kinder nach
europa gebracht die mehrheit der paare
benutzt private agenturen welche rasse
adoption anbieten mit der option
geschlecht und alter auszuwählen und
auch wie dunkelt die hautfarbe sein darf
[Musik]
für schweizer paare gibt es mehrere
möglichkeiten für die adoption staatlich
oder religiös geführte waisenhäuser aber
mit wenigen babys und langen wartezeiten
deshalb bieten sich zwei private
varianten an
in der schweiz alice honecker
vermittlerin aus st gallen
in sri lanka von da silva vermittlerin
in colombo beide arbeiten mit anwälten
zusammen welcher die adoption mit
falschen müttern amtlich beglaubigen ein
netz von vermittlern sucht mit allen
mitteln nach babys sie durchforschen die
dörfer und die geburtsstation in einem
umkreis von mehreren hundert kilometern
um colombo ihr ziel ledige mütter
manchmal werden babys gekauft für
mehrere dutzend dollar manchmal werden
sie den müttern weggenommen oder die
mütter geben sie unter druck ab
alice honecker inzwischen verstorben hat
mindestens 200 adoption organisiert
hauptsächlich in die deutschschweiz in
der westschweiz läuft der kontakt über
dorn da silva sie vermittelt mehr als
350 kinder in die schweiz
juni und monika weissbrodt sind
pensioniert und leben heute im kanton
bern als einer der wenigen adoptiveltern
erzählen sie von damals 1985 lebt
familie weissbrodt in collombey im
kanton neuenburg als eltern von zwei
söhnen möchten sie noch ein mädchen aus
sri lanka adoptieren
ein befreundetes ehepaar kam eines tages
mit einem baby auf sri lanka
es war so süß da dachten wir wir hätten
auch gern so ein kleines mädchen und
dank diesem paar haben sie sich mit frau
dass helfer in verbindung gesetzt
wir haben mist oder silver geschrieben
sie hat uns geantwortet dass das machbar
sei und wenn wir ein kleines mädchen
wollten dann könnten wir ein baby
bekommen und so ging das los
sie müssen zehn monate warten
in dieser zeit wird ihnen dreimal ein
neues baby versprochen hat sie das nicht
erstaunt es war uns nicht richtig
bewusst wir sagten uns dass sind arme
kinder und wir wir haben uns diese frage
nicht gestellt
ich weiß nicht damals das war ja
anwältin war dachten wir in der schweiz
dass man ihr vertrauen könne
wir konnten uns nicht vorstellen dass es
da nicht mit rechten dingen zugeht
aber da silva ist keine anwältin sie ist
reise agentin
sie bietet ihren kunden ein umfassendes
paket an unterkunft transport
übersetzung und natürlich ein kind zum
mitnehmen
sie kommt aus einer einflussreichen
familie und sie fordert geschenke ein um
den prozess zu beschleunigen
man muss der whisky mitbringen dann
schreibstifte und dann auch noch
schokolade
da stand 18 tafeln und uhren
das schon komisch aber wir dachten dort
funktioniert halt alles anders wir
wollten natürlich dass alles gut abläuft
also machten wir diese geschenke und
dachten uns das sei halt teil ihrer
kultur ihrer brüche
sie haben geschenke im wert von ungefähr
500 dollar dabei und noch vor der
abreise müssen 1500 dollar überwiesen
werden zusammen mit dem flugticket
beläuft sich die adoptions summe auf
etwa 5.000 dollar
[Musik]
als sie in colombo ankommen werden die
weissbrodt sofort abgeholt um ihr baby
in empfang zu nehmen
wir haben vor einem großen eisentor
angehalten man konnte nicht sehen was
dahinter waren das tor öffnete sich und
eine junge frau nach der anderen kam
heraus mit einem baby auf dem arm ganz
kleine und ein geschwisterpaar bei dem
die schwester etwas größer war
am ende kam es dann mit einem anderen
mädchen
sie legte uns unsere tochter in den arm
und sagte hier für sie das schönste weg
und es stimmt denn die war praktisch
weiß im vergleich zu den anderen kindern
sie war gut genährt das war die erste
begegnung mit unserer tochter waren das
die mütter der babys die da herauskam
nein ich glaube nicht
sie hatten nicht den eindruck das ist
die mütter waren ich dachte dass es
angestellte von westen waren es war klar
dass wir die mütter der kinder nicht
sehen sollten die weissbrodt ziehen mit
ihrem baby ins hotel
sie müssen zwei wochen warten bis die
papiere bereit sind
eine frau kommt ins gericht um die
adoption zur kunde zu unterzeichnen
glauben sie dass das die mutter von
sandy war
wir waren uns da ganz sicher es ist uns
gar nicht in den sinn gekommen dass es
anders sein könnte ihre tochter seien
die lebt heute in der nähe von paris und
sie wird in kürze mutter vor fünf jahren
hat sie die suche nach ihrer leiblichen
mutter aufgenommen
alleine aus angst die gefühle ihrer
adoptiveltern den sie sehr nahesteht zu
verletzen
in sri lanka findet sandi heraus dass
sie aus einer außerehelichen beziehung
stammt ihre tante hat sie verkauft im
hinterzimmer ihres lebensmittelladens
meine biologische familie dachte dass
ich in sri lanka sei das habe ich in sri
lanka erfahren denn am tag meine
adoption die im hinterzimmer des kleinen
laden stattfand kam ein mann und holte
mich ab
er erledigte das geschäftliche wenn man
dem so sagen will die familie dachte
dass ich bei diesem mann lebe einen
wohlhabenden geschäftsmann
sie dachten dass ich es bei ihnen gut
haben würde der mann ist aber in tat und
wahrheit einer der zulieferer von
dornbach silva und die adoptions urkunde
hat eine schauspieler mutter
unterzeichnet ja das ist kinderhandel
das ist nicht normal
man darf nicht mit menschen leben
spielen
damals ahnen die weissbrodt nichts von
alledem denn auf der schweizer botschaft
erhalten sie problemlos ein visum für
baby und das obschon die schweizer
behörden 1985 bereits wissen dass viele
adoptivkinder dubiose papiere haben
sie haben einfach nicht hingeschaut von
den adoptiveltern hat sich niemand
beklagt weshalb also sollten sie dem
nachgehen
in meinem fall ist es so dass das kind
auf dem foto im srilankischen pass
überhaupt nicht ähnlich aussieht wie das
kind auf dem foto auf den meine mutter
mich zum ersten mal im arm hält
es ist so offensichtlich dass ich mich
schon frage hat das niemand gesehen oder
hat es einfach niemanden interessiert
[Musik]
doch es gibt schon damals hinweise 1984
arbeitet pietro sutter als junger
sozialarbeiter für alice honecker er
wird nach colombo geschickt und wird
dort zweimal bei der schweizer botschaft
vorstellig
denn er hat bemerkt dass die für die
visa zuständige beamtin diese auch im
zweifelsfall aus stellt seinerseits
gesagt sei nur ausführendes organ vom
bundesamt für justiz
und wenn wenn die reduktion zu kunde da
ich gebe sie das messer aber es hätte
auch fälle gegeben wo das geburtsdatum
nicht über eingestanden hat mit
geburtsurkunde und und adoptions urkunde
und sie haben dann trotzdem visum
gegeben weil die eltern adoptiveltern
hätten ja nichts dafür können
empört über das vorgehen der botschaft
seines landes schreibt petra suthe einen
sehr kritischen bericht in sri lanka hat
der massen adoption gesehen mit shine
verfahren
er beschuldigt die lokalen vermittler
sich zu bereichern und die adoptiveltern
nicht hinzuschauen
die gesetze waren sehr offen sehr lasch
es gab keine kein gesetz also keine höhe
der adoptionsvermittlung jeder
vermittler konnte so viel verlangen wie
er wollte es gab keine limiten und das
war freier markt also von daher
es war sicher unmoralisch unethisch es
war einfach eine dienstleistung für
adoptiveltern die haben viel geld
bezahlt und bekamen einen guten service
also insoweit ist wahr dass ein business
von beiden seiten ein nein aber es war
nicht zum wohl der kinder
es war zum wohl der adoptiveltern pedro
suter will bei diesem handel nicht
mittäter sein
als er zurück in der schweiz ist
kündigte er seinen job
[Musik]
wir versuchen den sohn von alice
honecker zu kontaktieren
er ist selbst adoptiert und führt die
stiftung seiner mutter weiter in diesem
haus am zürichsee wo die honecker
antwortet uns schriftlich er verteidigt
die arbeit seiner mutter gibt uns aber
weder ein interview noch zugang zu
seinem archiv und was ist mit den
schweizer behörden haben sie wirklich
die augen verschlossen
wieso haben sie nicht interveniert um
das herauszufinden verlangen wir zugang
zu diplomatischen korrespondenz der 80er
jahre zwischen der schweizer botschaft
in sri lanka und bern ein heikles thema
zu beginn erhalten wir keine einsicht
erlaubnis vom bund es wird geltend
gemacht dass bei adoptionen eine
außergewöhnliche frist von 120 jahren
gilt es braucht mehrere wochen
verhandlungen
dann erhält terry hartmann recherche
journalist von rts eine
ausnahmeerlaubnis um die vertraulichen
dokumente anzuschauen aber die
bedingungen sind sehr strikt es darf
nichts kopiert und nichts fotografiert
werden
einzig notizen vor ort sind erlaubt in
diesem kartons steckt ein gut gehütetes
geheimnis
die schweizer behörden wussten seit
beginn der 80er jahre vom kind handel
bei internationalen adoption bereits
1981 zeigt sich ein diplomat in colombo
beunruhigt claude ochsenbein
am 12 oktober 1981 schreibt er in seinem
dossier über don da silva eines tages
wird uns diese angelegenheit einholen
und wir werden in etwas verwickelt sein
was ein skandal werden könnte
zwei monate später verständigt boxen
weinbergen ein herr wettstein vom
bundesamt für ausländerfragen antwortet
ihm am 22
dezember 1981 sie sehen nur befugt das
visum auszustellen wenn sie sicher sind
dass die vorgängigen adoption schritte
in abstimmung mit den lokalen gesetzen
stattgefunden haben
[Musik]
diese weisung bringt den schweizer
diplomaten in colombo in eine unmögliche
situation wenn er die vorgelegten
dokumente zurückweist bedeutet das dass
die srilankischen gerichte korrupt sind
außerdem wird die botschaft vor
vollendete tatsachen gestellt die
schweizer eltern kommen in der regel
bereits mit dem baby und den
srilankischen adoptions dokumenten an
was also tun
claude ochsenbein antwortet dem
bundesamt für ausländerfragen mit einem
detaillierten bericht
er bemängelt dass die schweizer
adoptiveltern vor ort druck ausüben
würden
er teilt sie in zwei kategorien ein
am dritten mai 1985 schreibt er für die
einen eltern zählt das geld und die
moralischen vorstellungen sind etwas
ausgeprägter sie wehren sich gegen die
forderungen der vermittler und dann gibt
es die andere kategorie der eltern für
sie spielt das geld keine rolle
sie wollen möglichst schnell ans ziel
kommen
ein beispiel ein arzt erklärt auf der
botschaft dass er 1000 franken pro tag
verdient und deshalb keine zeit zu
verlieren habe
einige tage später reiste ab ganz stolz
mit seinem baby empört schreibt der
diplomat
es fragt sich wie viele unsere mitbürger
in diesem zusammenhang eine schwere
verantwortung zu tragen haben
bern hat keine zeit auf den
unmissverständlichen berichtes
diplomaten zu reagieren
eine woche später am 19 mai 1982 gelang
der skandal um die illegalen adoptionen
an die öffentlichkeit
die zeitschrift l'illustré
veröffentlicht einen schockierenden
bericht der artikel bezieht sich auf die
privaten organisationen die adoption
vermitteln
von da silva wird beschrieben als eine
der wichtigsten kinder händlerinnen der
hauptstadt weiter steht geschrieben die
kinder die zum verkauf stehen sind
simple exportprodukte sie werden in
massen gehalten
sie sind in fünf bis sechs heimen
untergebracht welche die einwohner baby
fans nennen
gemäss der zeitschrift stoße das alles
bei den schweizer behörden auf taube
ohren
für die schweizer zollbeamten zähle nur
das die papiere des kindes korrekt sein
steht da
das ist auch die linie des bundesrats im
juni 1982 erklärt kurt furgler dass es
in sri lanka vielleicht ein problem gäbe
mit gewissen lokalen vermittlern aber
nicht in der schweiz trotz der
anschuldigungen des diplomaten in
colombo und der zeitungsartikel machen
die schweizer behörden 1982 nichts um
den skandal zu stoppen und private
adoptionen zu verbieten
[Musik]
und auch die adoptiveltern wollen ihren
kinderwunsch nicht aufgeben
mit der hilfe von alice honecker und
dorn da silva kommen in den folgenden
vier jahren weiterhin hunderte
srilankischer babys in die schweiz
[Musik]
doch im januar 1987 wird dann das silva
verhaftet ihr wird vorgeworfen ihr hotel
in einer baby farm verwandelt zu haben
einige monate später gibt es wie lanka
die internationalen adoptionen auf doch
es wird noch 30 jahre dauern bis die
behörden im herbst 2017 das ausmaß des
handels in den 80er jahren zu geben
werden
es gab viele solche baby fans war in
meinem bezirk in der nähe des strandes
sie führten dort eine razzia durch und
nahmen einige leute fest
in diesem baby farmen haben sie babys
gesammelt und an ausländer verkauft
für eine adoption in der schweiz mit
olivia und sarah klar dass sie mit ihrem
schicksal nicht allein sind die meisten
kinder die in den 80er jahren aus sri
lanka adoptiert wurden haben falsche
papiere
sie beschließen einen verein zu gründen
70 adoptierte treten sofort bei
inzwischen sind es bereits 120
[Musik]
wir möchten das problem auch politisch
angehen damit wir sicher sein können
dass so etwas nicht wieder vorkommt dass
anerkannt wird was damals geschehen ist
das wäre schon sehr wichtig die
schweizer behörden wussten bescheid
darüber was vor 35 jahren geschehen ist
es ist nicht so dass sie nichts gewusst
haben oder nichts hätten wissen können
sie sagten sich wohl gut die
adoptiveltern haben ihr baby bekommen
alle sind zufrieden und haben nicht
weitergedacht
die schweiz muss diese verantwortung
auch tragen sie kann nicht einfach alles
auf das geburtsland der babys abschieben
ihr aufruf wird gehört auch im bundesrat
er hat ein postulat angenommen welches
zum ziel hat licht ins dunkel zu bringen
bei der adoption auf sri lanka das
bundesamt für justiz hat zwei jahre zeit
um einen bericht zu erstellen
wir haben ganz klar die aufgabe die
adoptierten kinder zu unterstützen bei
der suche nach ihren wurzeln
diese aufgabe steht in der verfassung in
diesem zusammenhang stellt sich die
frage ob es zu rechtswidrigkeiten oder
unregelmäßigkeiten gekommen ist und in
der folge dann zu entscheiden was man
damit macht oder was man noch zusätzlich
machen kann
die adoptierten aus dem verein haben
klare erwartungen
sie verlangen unter anderem
psychologische unterstützung und
finanzielle hilfe des bundes für die
suche nach ihren wurzeln
doch die dinge gehen langsam voran das
dossier hat in bundesbern keine hohe
priorität
sie haben keine zusätzlichen mittel kein
zusätzliches personal bekommen um den
bericht zu verfassen
die behörde für adoptionen ist sehr
knapp bemessen wir sind drei personen
von denen sich momentan keine voll
diesem dossier widmen kann
[Musik]
natalie ist mit ihrem älteren bruder
adoptiert worden
sie hat 2001 mit der unterstützung ihrer
adoptiveltern eine frau gefunden von der
sie glaubt dass sie ihrer mutter ist nun
will sie gewissheit sarah macht für
natalie einen dna test in sri lanka ich
hatte schon das gefühl dass diese frau
meine mutter ist denn es war sehr
emotional
sie weinte und sagte sie sei so vor uns
wieder zu sehen
diese frau hat tatsächlich zwei kinder
zur adoption freigegeben ein junge und
ein mädchen
aber da bleibt ein kleiner zweifel ob
sie wirklich meine leibliche mutter ist
[Musik]
sarah macht sich also mit einem
übersetzer auf den weg in das kleine
arme dorf im norden columbus sie trifft
hier die frau die natalies mutter sein
soll
[Musik]
in diesem brief hat sie gefragt ob sie
einverstanden sind mit einem dna-test
sie sagt sie würde das gerne tun
sie sagt weil es ihre kinder seien
möchte sie das gerne tun
fünf wochen wird es dauern bis das
testresultat vorliegt
ich hoffe wirklich dass ich nach all den
jahren nun die bestätigung bekommen
denn wenn nicht beginne ich wieder bei
null
das würde bedeuten dass all meine
papiere gefälscht sind
dass die fotos die ich meinen kindern
gezeigt habe als die fragen stellten gar
nicht mich als baby zeigen es gelingt
sogar in diesem abgelegenen dorf den
kontakt in die schweiz herzustellen
hallo meine tochter hallo mama sie
möchte sie gerne sehen und vor allem
ihre kinder
sie sagt es ist schön ihre stimme zu
hören
[Musik]
sie möchte sie gerne sehen
sie hat mehrmals betont dass sie kein
geld bekommen hat als ihr euch beide weg
gegeben hat sie hat mehrmals gesagt ich
habe meine kinder nicht verkauft
[Musik]
die frau erklärt im gespräch dass sie
damals allein und mittellos krank
geworden sei im spital hat eine
krankenschwester die in kontakt war mit
dem dach silvers organisationen sie
überredet ihre kinder abzugeben
[Musik]
ich habe erfahren dass sie uns zwar
freiwillig abgegeben hat aber das doch
ein gewisser druck da war das macht
einen großen unterschied dass sie
offenbar nicht genau wusste was sie tat
vor allem rechnete sie damit uns wieder
zu sehen
heute bin ich ja selbst mutter und kann
mir gar nicht vorstellen wie das für sie
gewesen sein muss denken sie dass man
ihr nicht genau erklärt hat was das
beinhaltet offensichtlich nicht man hat
ihr nicht erklärt was eine adoption
bedeutet sie rechnete damit uns wieder
zu sehen und erst dort hat sie begriffen
was sie getan hat
[Musik]
die adoptierten kinder sind nicht die
einzigen die ihre familien nieder finden
wollen
auch mütter suchen nach ihren kindern
die in den 80er jahren als babys
adoptiert worden
doch das thema bleibt ein tabu in sri
lanka die behörden helfen den frauen
nicht und dna tests sind für sie nicht
bezahlbar
der verein von sarah und olivia hat eine
warteliste von etwa 100 frauen
srilankische frauen können es sich nicht
leisten einen dna test zu machen unsere
arbeit und die arbeit von anderen
adoptierten ist also sehr wichtig wir
sind erst noch am anfang wir haben mit
elf dna kids begonnen und es gibt 11.000
adoptierte auf der ganzen welt
es gibt also noch viel zu tun aber man
muss ja irgendwo anfangen
mit diesen stäbchen werden hautzellen
für den dna test entnommen
die resultate werden anschließend an
eine internationale datenbank gegeben
die frauen hoffen dass ihre kinder sie
jedenfalls suchen und dass sie sich über
die datenbank dank übereinstimmende dna
finden
es sieht so aus als ob diese mütter ihre
kinder freiwillig abgegeben haben
aber man ist sich vielleicht nicht
bewusst unter welchem druck die mutter
standen entweder wurden die kinder ihnen
legal wird genommen
oder sie wurden dazu gezwungen die
kinder abzugeben oder die eigene familie
hat druck ausgeübt
sie konnten sehr wenig entscheiden
um nicht zu sagen gar nichts
einig
diese frau erzählt dass sie sehr jung
geheiratet hat gegen den willen ihrer
eltern
sie war schwanger als ihr mann sie
verließ ihre familie zwang sie ihr baby
wegzugeben
ich suche seit etwa 18 jahren ich weiß
es nicht mehr ganz genau
sie kamen am 15 juni 1977 in der
customer journey in colombo zur welt sie
heißt anusha kumari ich dachte damals
dass auch wenn ich sie weg gebe ich sie
zu einem späteren zeitpunkt wieder sehen
würde
ich war völlig hilflos
ich möchte mein kind wieder sehen bevor
ich sterbe
um herauszufinden wer ihre papiere
gefälscht hat verfolgt olivia noch eine
andere spur
sie will dorn da silva finden die
vermittlerin welche ihre adoption
organisiert hat die frau ist seit
mehreren jahrzehnten verschwunden
gerüchten zufolge soll sie in
kalifornien oder australien leben im
telefonbuch finden wir eine dorn da
silva
die adresse führt uns in eine bessere
gegend von colombo einer nachbarin zeigt
uns welches haus wir können es selbst
nicht fassen als wir sie in ihrem garten
antreffen
wir erkennen sie sofort zuerst streitet
sie ab dorn das silber zu sein
doch als wir sie mit den dokumenten
konfrontieren gibt sie es zu wir
improvisieren und filmen mit unseren
handys don dass jede war sagt dass sie
keine unterlagen aus jener zeit mehr
besitzt sie erinnern sich nicht an die
namen und sie haben keine unterlagen
mehr kein archiv nein sie haben gar
keine papiere aus der zeit gar nichts
nein wir konfrontieren sie mit fotos und
briefen die sie verschickt hat aber sie
erinnert sich an kein baby das doch sie
vermittelt worte weder an olivia noch an
sein die noch an natalie an niemanden
mein ganzes leben lang dachte ich sie
seien die anwältin welchem eine adoption
durchführte und mich meiner mutter
weggenommen hatte nein das ist nicht
meine schuld
verstehen sie dass es für diese kinder
heute sehr belastend ist dass sie ihre
leiblichen eltern nicht finden können
das verstehe ich aber ich habe die
kinder und ihre geburtsurkunden nicht
ausgesucht
ich weiß nichts darüber ich habe sie nur
ins büro von herrn carrera gebracht und
dann mussten die eltern vor einem anwalt
unterschreiben und das war es aber sie
haben nie die biologischen mutter
getroffen die ihre kinder zur adoption
freigeben
die kamen immer mit den vermittlern
es gab aber frauen die nicht die mütter
waren die aber die papiere unterzeichnen
das müssen sie die vermittler fragen sie
haben alles gemacht aber sie hatten doch
auch schauspieler mütter nein ich hatte
damit nichts zu tun mit den adoptionen
die diskussion wird immer zu realer bonn
das silva behauptet ihre verhaftung 1987
sei ein abgekartetes spiel gewesen
die rache eines eifersüchtigen ex mannes
das war alles erfunden gab es denn keine
baby farbe
ich wurde vom generalstaatsanwalt
entlastet dadurch bekam ich mein visum
und ging nach australien und die usa
denn ich habe nichts damit zu tun ich
hatte nur übersetzt und die reise
organisiert
sonst weiß ich nichts sie haben keine
baby farm in vaduz betrieben nein das
ist alles erfunden erfunden also waren
sie denn nicht im gefängnis
für kurze zeit ja wie lange etwa eine
woche artikeln aus dieser zeit zufolge
ist es ihr aufgrund eines
verfahrensfehlers gelungen das gefängnis
zu umgehen
danach ist sie in die usa geflüchtet und
sie scheint nichts zu bereuen was würden
sie denn all diesen kindern und babys
sagen die sind doch teil sicher
glücklich oder ich denke einige wären
sonst im abfall gelandet
danach habe ich viele solche sachen wir
sehen im abfall gelandet in sri lanka
ja sie denken sie hätten sie vor einem
schlimmen leben in sri lanka gerettet
schmerzhafte worte für olivia
viele mütter sind sehr traurig dass sie
ihre kinder verloren haben
alles was sie wollen ist ihre kinder zu
finden bevor sie sterben tut ihnen das
nicht leid ich denke schon aber sie
haben doch sicher ein besseres leben
gehabt als in sri lanka ich weiß nicht
wie mein leben hier verlaufen wäre
aber ich wäre bei meiner mutter gewesen
mein ganzes leben lang habe ich meiner
mutter vermisst das ist sehr traurig für
mich ich verstehe sind sie wirklich
sicher dass sie sich nicht an olivia
hamm jahr erinnern was möchten sie ihr
gern sagen ich hoffe dass sie ihre
mutter findet
[Musik]
am nächsten tag schickt uns dorn das
silva ein e-mail mit den namen der
vermittler
doch die meisten sind bereits gestorben
es gibt keine spur mehr die weiter
verfolgen könnten
sie bedroht uns und verbietet uns wieder
zu kommen
wir versuchen also sie per telefon zu
erreichen aber ihre nummer ist nicht
mehr gültig
[Musik]
fünf wochen später treffen wir natalie
in rom wieder
sie hat das resultat ihres dna tests
erhalten
er ist positiv
sie hat ihre leibliche mutter gefunden
zum ersten mal in meinem leben haben
sich meine schultern entspannt ich habe
weniger probleme mit der atmung auch mit
der verdauung
ich glaube das spielt alles zusammen
denn ohne das mäßig bewusst ist der
körper erinnert sich und daran löste
sich plötzlich eine enorme anspannung
ich bin sehr dankbar denn ich kenne
andere personen die ihre leibliche
mutter ebenfalls lange suchten und dann
am ende einen negativen bescheid
bekommen
das ist extrem hart ich weiß was für ein
glücklicher
[Musik]
und meine kinder sind nun in einem alter
wo sie anfangen die fragen zu stellen
ich habe immer ein bisschen gezögert
ihnen zu antworten weil ich nicht sicher
war das hat sich nun geändert
nun kann ich ihnen sagen dass wir
dorthin fliegen können wenn sie das
möchten
ich finde das sehr wichtig dass sie es
wissen und dass sie das nicht
durchmachen müssen diese recherche
arbeit all die offenen fragen sie wilden
antworten haben und das ist sehr wichtig
für ihre identität
olivia sucht weiter sie fühlt sich gut
in sri lanka und möchte so oft wie
möglich hierher zurückkehren
aber anders als sarah und natalie plant
sie im moment keine eigene familie
ich glaube nicht dass sich kinder haben
werde
ich weiß dass es für einige sehr heilsam
war neue wurzeln zu schlagen
ich fühle mich nicht bereit mutter zu
sein denn zuerst muss ich mich noch um
das kleine verletzte kind kümmern dass
immer noch in mir drin ist
[Musik]
diesen schmerz das gefühl entwurzelt
worden zu sein trägt auch sarah mit sich
aber sie bereut es nicht ihre
vergangenheit aufgerollt zu haben
im alltag findet sie trost in ihrem
beruf als hebamme im alter von zwölf
jahren wusste ich dass dies mein beruf
werden sollte rückblickend denke ich
heute dass die begleitung der werdenden
mütter und ihre babys sehr heilsam
fällig war
für mich ist das immer noch ein
geheimnis diese mutter bbc aber sie
haben noch hoffnung ihre leibliche
mutter zu finden
ja ich habe noch hoffnung
aber man muss eine gute balance finden
damit es nicht zur obsession wird
ich habe ja mein leben meine familie
meine kinder hier auf der anderen seite
wie soll man jemals aufhören seine
familie zu suchen
ich denke die hoffnung wird bis zuletzt
bleiben
[Musik]